vous annoncez nous allons la voir dans
quelques instants je me disais que cette
interview était enregistrée hier après
midi de même que le clip qui suit cette
interview céline dion tout de suite
céline dion votre première chanson
c'était comme dans un rêve je crois ce
n'était qu'un rêve
oui mais ça c'est mon premier 45 tours
québécois savent pas mais c'est toujours
un rêve
vous avez 19 ans je crois et vous êtes
toujours dans un rêve bah oui et non
parce que bon c'est un rêve depuis
toujours de chanter je connais juste la
musique et mes frères et soeurs font de
la musique aussi chantent et jouent
désastreuse et alors on vous voit pas
souvent en france c'est parce que vous
êtes très occupé là bas au québec dont
on ne voit pas souvent un frein j'essaie
de venir quand même assez régulièrement
je pense bon à peu près là en grand
simon au québec six mois en france
j'essaie de venir le plus souvent
possible
mais au québec vous chanter sur scène
vous êtes accompagné par des musiciens
ou fait de la scène alors qu'en france
on n'a pas eu le plaisir encore de vous
voir sur scène à écouter ça fait six ans
que je que je chante déjà j'ai commencé
ma carrière chez nous avant de venir en
france
et puis j'ai quand même vite 30 cm les
huiles en jeu chez nous donc je peux me
permettre maintenant avec autant de
répertoire de faire de la scène
ici j'ai quelques 45 tours mais je crois
que j'ai passé le matériel encore
j'aimerais ça j'ai quand même fait
l'olympia pendant six semaines tous les
soirs avec patrick sébastien
ça a été un grand honneur j'espère de
pouvoir leur faim et vous vous préparez
bien pour la scène en tout cas parce que
je crois savoir vous prenez des cours de
danse
ben oui je prends des cours de danse je
prends des cours de chant j'ai arrêté
l'école mais j'étais toujours pour mon
métier parce que j'ai envie de faire du
cinéma aussi je veux chanter toute ma
vie je veux chanter dans toutes les
langues possibles et impossibles je veux
voyager beaucoup j'adore communiquer
avec les gens je veux faire or
l'actualité pour vous c'est un nouveau
45 euros qui vient de sortir une
nouvelle chanson c'est un virage parce
que c'est quand même un peu différent ce
titre avait quand même différent oui
c'est pas une innovation
on s'est tout simplement quelque chose
que j'avais envie de faire j'avais le
goût de souligner un petit peu plus mais
j'ai encore le goût de chanter des
chansons romantiques mais je veux je
veux bouger aussi mais je veux tout me
permettre je veux faire du jazz je veux
faire plein de choses auraient écouté
cette chanson vous nous donner le titre
je ne veux pas voilà céline dion merci
et à très bientôt bientôt